>> Hello to
the online world here.
It's a pleasure to have
Niek Bouman visiting
us from Eindhoven.
Today, Niek has been actually
in pretty much all the big
places in the Netherlands.
You've been at CWI,
you've been, at ABN AMRO,
and Eindhoven and you're
getting the game
enlightened also, right?
>> Right.
>> Niek has done
good deal of work on
Multi-Party Computation as well
as some quantum computation work,
if you're interested in that,
come let's talk later.
But in particular, he's going
to tell us about work on
efficient Multi-Party
Computation for
algebraic structures especially,
if that's an appropriate
description.
So, welcome, thank you.
>> Yes. Thank you very much Josh.
Thank you for having me here.
So, I will talk about
Multi-party Computation
Research at
the Technical University
of Eindhoven,
and we are there
in the group with
Berry Schoenmakers from Rome
and Universiteit Leiden.
So, many of the things
that I will talk
about is joint work with them.
The plan for today is to present
you MPyC which is
a Python framework
developed mainly by
Berry Schoenmakers
for performing
Multi-Party Computation,
and this framework is not so much
tailored to a
production environment,
but more as a tool for
research in a rapid
prototyping environments.
Then I will talk about performing
linear algebra over the
rationals in an MPC setting,
and if time allows,
I will say something about
a comparison with
secure comparison,
but if there is no time and
you're interested in that,
so, please see me after the talk.
So, let's motivate MPyC or MPC,
why do we want to have
Multi-Party Computation?
At the following example,
let us suppose that
the US Census Bureau wants
to compute statistics
over medical records.
Well, in a world without MPC,
the hospitals will have to send
the medical records to
the Census Bureau or
the Census Bureau
Query Stem and then
compute the statistics
that it wants to compute.
But with Multi-Party Computation,
we can have a better situation
in terms of data privacy,
namely the hospitals can run
a interactive protocol together
with the Census Bureau,
so that the Census Bureau
gets in the end to
the desired statistics.
By the way, the hospitals
and the Census Bureau
agree on what statistics are
allowed to be computable,
however, the Census Bureau
does nothing beyond
this statistic.
So, let's describe this a bit
more formally or maybe
forgets the application,
let's just talk about
what MPC can do.
So, here we talk about
three parties that each
holds a private input,
and the parties want to compute
some function that takes
these private inputs
such that no party learns
more than what can
be deduced from her input and
the output of the function.
So, there's an
example we could be
interested in learning
the sum of those inputs,
or the sum and some
product as given
there by F2 or
maybe even what you want
to make a comparison,
but let's not talk about
that yet in this talk.
Yeah. Well, how to
how to achieve this.
So, Multi-party Computation
comes in two flavors;
Garbled circuits and
Arithmetic Secret Sharing.
I don't want to
exhaustively explain
what especially the
first type means,
but I just want to say to
the experts in this field,
I want to scope the talk
that I only want
to talk about Arithmetic
Secret Sharing here.
Well, Arithmetic Secret Sharing
goes back actually
to a paper by Blakley and also
a paper by Shamir
from the late '70s.
Here the question
is, how can we share
a secret among several players?
Well, we can do that with
the polynomials in
the following way,
we assume that we work
over a finite field,
here I took the integers
modulo prime,
and I choose the prime
strictly larger than
the number of players n,
and I choose
a threshold parameter,
which is an integer,
which is strictly
smaller than n over two,
and we are here targeting
the passively secure case,
which means that the parties
they follow the protocol,
but still, they tried to learn
as much as possible from
all the protocol transcripts.
Now, we choose a random
polynomial up to degree t,
such that the polynomial
evaluated at the point
zero equals the secret.
As you can think of a picture in
your head which
doesn't make sense
completely because if we
are here working over
finite fields so the dashed
part doesn't exist of course.
But in this way, we could
evaluate the polynomial
in other points than zero
and give the evaluations.
So, the y value to the
different parties,
and if we evaluate
that polynomial
at enough places namely;
t plus one points,
then those evaluations
define the polynomial and
allows the parties to reconstruct
the polynomial and
reconstruct with that
the secret by evaluating
the polynomial at point zero.
On the other hand, t
evaluation points,
they don't give any
information about the secret,
so, this is the
threshold property.
>> Can I ask quickly why you
are restricting the thresholds to
less than half the
parameters that's
nearly larger to
less than n of two?
>> Yes, I wanted
to make the parameters
concrete here.
>> Okay.
>> Yes. So, a bit of notation.
So, I use this double brackets
for a secret shared value so,
this means that a is
from the finite field,
and the parties each
hold a share of a.
Then I can perform
operations with
those secret shared values,
I can perform addition
which is actually
local computation, so,
there is no interaction required
between the players to
compute the addition,
and there's multiplication
which is more expensive in
the sense that now
the parties have
to communicate to each other.
The reason for this
is that if you do
point-wise multiplication
of a polynomial,
then you end up with
a higher degree.
So, you need some protocol to
bring back the degree to
what you started with,
and that requires
the communication.
So, if you want to perform
computations with
MPC and practice,
then it's convenient
to have some kind of
framework that helps you with
implementing all this
communication logic
and arithmetic over
finite fields.
So, hence there are
MPC frameworks,
and here is a list
of such frameworks.
The first one was Fairplay from
2004 and since then there
have been several frameworks,
and these frameworks are
all for Arithmetic
Secret Sharing.
So, there are also Garbled
circuits based MPC frameworks,
but I don't mention them here.
In this talk, I want to
present to you MPyC which
is mainly developed by
Berry Schoenmakers
from the TU Eindhoven,
and was inspired by VIFF,
which is also mentioned here in
the list which was
from Eindhoven University
from Geisler et al.
So, if we classify
MPC frameworks within
The Arithmetic Secret Sharing,
then we could distinguish between
Library-based
frameworks and Domain
specific language
based frameworks.
So, in a Library-based framework,
the MPyC functions are
just library calls,
and you can mix those calls
with features that
the host language offers you.
So, for example, if you need to
compute a genre symbol then you
just use the feature provided
by some other library,
and you can mix that with
your MPyC protocols.
Whereas, there are also
frameworks out there who
offer a Domain specific language,
and the latter might be better
suited for correctness
verification.
But on the other end,
if you need something
that is already there
in the host language,
then you first need some way to
import that or make
it available in
your little world with
the specific language.
But yes, both approaches
have their pros and cons,
but MPyC is a framework
of the first kind.
So, let's talk about how
MPyC works under the hood,
about the Execution Model.
So, if I want to compute
say two products
in succession right here
the E depends on
the value of C. So,
first I have to compute C,
and then I can compute E.
If I will do that in
a synchronous
programming environment,
then you basically have to wait
till C is available
and only then you can
start computing E. Because here
a multiplication
involves communication
between the parties,
you have to actually wait for
this packets to go out to
the other parties and
the other parties do something,
and then send you
the packet back,
before you can start
your next multiplication.
So, this would be slow,
and hence VIFF
introduced this and
also MPyC uses
the asynchronous model,
where you create a task
for an operation
that would require
network communication and
it would immediately return
you some objects that
indicates that you will get
that value in the future.
In Python that is
called the Future,
or in some other languages
it's called an Awaitable,
but it's all part
of the same idea.
So, you can build up
a computation graph
with these futures,
and then at the end await
the future and get the results.
There's also a notion
of coroutines that you
can map these kind of
operations on a single thread,
if you want or on a thread pool.
But the benefits of this
asynchronous execution model,
is that you can already look
ahead and see what is coming,
and you can already
execute local work which you
might need in the future.
So, for example, if your
protocol requires a random bits,
you might do some or you might
require a pre-computation,
that you can already carry out.
So, it's in some sense
a hybrid form
of greedy and lazy execution.
You want to be greedy in
the sense that all
the local work that you have
to perform before sending
out a network packet,
you want to do greedily,
while all the work
that would come after
the response of
your fellow parties,
that you schedule lazily.
So, you can push all kinds
of work on the CPU,
or you can make or
keep the CPU busy,
even though you are waiting
for network packets to arrive.
Oh there's a question.
Yes, please.
>> Do you also combine jobs
the network communications
so that you have
fewer connections
sending more data at once?
>> There's a question, whether
we amortize network traffic?
So, whether we combine
several things in a packet.
Yes, that's also a method
that you can use,
and I know that VIFF uses that
for some operations but I,
all right sorry,
MPyC uses that for
some operations maybe
not for all but that
is indeed a technique that
you can use as well to
make things more efficient.
But on the other hand,
you could also say,
that a network packet is
quite small in itself.
So, also the operating system,
does some chunking there,
it cuts the stream in packets.
So, as long as you make sure
that you fill that pipe,
that stream, then you get
that behavior that you
suggest, all of it.
>> Because you have
long-lived connection
between adhesive
>> Yes, there is
a long-lived connection
between all the parties.
Yes. So, this asynchronous model
has these benefits so that
you can keep the CPUs busy.
However, you need some way
of throttle the computation.
In the sense that if
you would set out
all the work that your algorithm
is going to require
at once then you might
fill up the memory if
this executor goes greedily
through your code.
Say through a long loop and
keeps setting out new work,
and then at some point
you fill up
the memory so you need
to throttle there.
But there's also
a mechanism in MPyC,
called Barrier, which is
meant for that purpose.
Okay, these we're some slides
about the theory of MPyC.
Let's see it in practice.
For that I'm going to
switch to a different view.
So, here I am in a
Jupyter notebook
and one of the nice
features of MPyC,
is that it can run in
a single party mode in Jupyter.
This is maybe a bit
counter-intuitive because we do
Multi-Party Computation then
why would you be interested
in running a single party mode.
Well, that is very useful
for debugging purposes.
So, it has the same API.
So, exactly the
same script can be
run in multiple
instances of Python,
and of course you need
some small configuration
file to tell at
which ports those different notes
are listening so that
they can find each other,
but when you set
that up you can run
exactly the same code as in
this single-player mode.
By the way, if you
are in a notebook and
you haven't installed
it you can install
it by this single line of
code, this!pip install MPyC.
So here, I'm going to
import the package,
I'm going to define
a secret integer type,
and now I can perform
a computation.
So, I can make a value three,
make a value five,
which are secret integers
and compute the product,
and this MPyC output will say
that it reveals the product.
So, I open the result
immediately.
Okay, nothing happens so far.
I created the Z or Z,
I can inspect what to Z means.
It's a co-routine object.
So, that means that
here we were greedily,
so we we've returned immediately
but nothing happened,
I still have to run
that co-routine.
So, let us do that
with this line,
and I get the value 15.
Okay, now you might wonder
what is going on here
because well you have
multiplied the numbers
three and five,
and it's 15, I believe that.
But where is the randomness here?
Because here there's
only a single party
who inputs three and five,
and if you would now copy
this instance to
say three parties,
it would still be three and five.
So, the parties would
actually share
a constant polynomial,
so that's not really useful.
Well, it is useful for
development purposes again,
but we keep in mind that
this is a simplification,
because if you would really
use this in a multiparty setting,
you would have to
branch on the party ID,
and the parties will of course
input different data because
that's the entire purpose
of doing Multi-Party
Computation that
different parties have
different pieces of information.
But again, this is
just a nice simplification,
that we can use to
input values and then
we can compute with
those values as
if we were computing
with values that
are originating originating
from a single-player.
Well, another example
here is that I can
create a secret
random field element,
and this happens to be
the random field element.
By the way, I can inspect
in what fields I'm working.
>> So, that X is secret shared?
>> X is secret shared, indeed.
Yes. Here we see that we
have a 64 bit modulus,
and I can inspect more,
I can inspect the bit length
of the secret integer,
which is only 32 bits.
That again, seems to
contradict each other,
but the reason why
this bit length
which conveys to usable bit
length for the user,
is only 32 bits,
because we have
this headroom that you need
for a secure comparison operator.
Well, I've got another example
here to create a random bit.
Well, it seems to
be a random bit.
Also here, I show
an implementation of
a protocol that could
create a random bit.
So, here I start with creating
a secret shared field element.
Then I open the product
or the square of
that field element.
Then I compute the inverse
of the square root
of that square.
Then I multiply X,
the original random field element
with this inverted square root,
which gives me minus
one or plus one at random.
Then with this small
transformation,
plus one divided by two,
I go to two bits.
I even have here
a small example of comparison.
So, I have two values,
one and two,
and I want to compare them
together or compare
them to each other.
Indeed, X is not
strictly bigger than Y,
so I get a zero here.
If I would change the code,
then I get a one.
So, this is a small introduction.
Let's now go back to
the second part of my talk.
>> Why are you doing [inaudible].
Why are you doing
such a complicated degeneration?
We really a benefit to that
over generator in
field element [inaudible].
>> The question is
why I generate a random
bits in this fashion.
Do you mean that
your question why
the random bit function is
implemented in the above fashion?
>> Yes.
>> Yes, that's thing, that's why,
because I think there are
several random bit protocols
and each of them have
some constraint.
One question is whether you want
to have perfect correcting
something and let's
say it's fine.
Okay, the next part
of my talk will
be about secure linear algebra
over the rationals.
This is a joint work
with Frank Blom,
Berry Schoenmakers,
and Niels de Vreede.
I want to rescope the setting,
I'm still in secret sharing
based multi-party
computation and I
focus on the multi-party scenario
with a larger or equal
than three players.
I assume that I have
some arithmetic black
box at my disposal,
which provides me with
say an addition operation
and multiplication operation
and opening values, etc.
So, I don't specify exactly
which MPC framework I use.
I view it as an API that
is there that I can use.
Now my problem, that I want
to consider is that I have
a full rank square matrix A
and vector B with
integral coefficients,
all these those entries
are secret shared
among the parties.
Now, I want to solve the
linear system AX equals B.
So, I want to solve for x,
I want to do this over
the rational numbers.
To use correct pronunciation.
So, what is the motivation here,
I viewed irrational numbers as
some kind of approximation
to the real numbers and
engineers usually want to
solve linear algebra problems
over the real numbers
and if they come to
the cryptographers and they say,
"Hey, we have
some privacy problem.
We want to solve
a linear algebra problem
in the context of MPC."
Well, then maybe
the rational numbers are
the closest arithmetic
structure to work over,
which mimics the reals.
We are interested in
data processing applications
or secure statistics, etc.
If we look at the related work,
then there is related work
by Thomas Tuft from 2009,
works over rationals in
MPC in the context of
solving linear programs.
Then the two party case,
there are some references
mentioned there.
But I focus on
the multi-party case.
If we think about performing
arithmetic in
a finite field in MPC.
Then think about
integer arithmetic
versus rational arithmetic.
Well, let's first say
that integer arithmetic
is easy to do.
So, we have the correspondence
between the integers minus
P over two to plus P over
two truncated or float,
as long as we don't wrap
around the modulus,
we keep this correspondence,
so we can perform additions,
multiplications, and it's as if,
we were working over the integers
when our prime is big enough.
With rational arithmetic, we
could do a division because
we're in a finite field.
Then the division would be
multiplication by
the multiplicative inverse of B.
As long as A and B
are small enough,
then there's still
a correspondence.
It's just that if we would
look at this field element x.
We don't recognize there
anything human, right?
If, you would divide,
if you would compute
two over three.
You get some humongous
fields element
and with rational reconstruction,
you can still reconstruct
these numerator and denominator,
namely by performing
a lattice basis reduction.
You encode the basis as
shown here on the slides.
If you run Lagrange-Gauss,
you will eventually,
get back A and B.
The problem however, is
if you want to perform
this in a secure
multi-party computation,
you must be constant time
or data independent.
So, you would have to
run this algorithm for
the worst case and
pad it with with
dummy operations.The
worst case was analyzed
by Brigitte Vallee is
order log p iterations,
where in every iteration,
you would have to do
an integer divisions,
so division with the truncation.
So, that would be impractical
in multi-party computation.
So, our approach is different.
If, we look at the problem
of solving linear system.
Well, let's just invert a matrix
because we have
a full rank matrix.
Numerical people would
never compute an inverse,
but here, we are doing
exact arithmetic.
So, we don't have condition
numbers to worry about.
You can think about
the inverse as
the adjugate matrix of A
divided by its determinants.
Where both of these objects like
the adjugate and the determinants
are over the integers.
So again, if we have
a prime that is big enough,
we can embed them in
the finite field.
So, this representation
of the solution,
prevents the occurrence of
rational entries and with that,
we don't need to
irrational reconstruction.
So, here we work
over the field of
p. We are going to
compute the inverse of
A via modified protocol
from Cramer and Damgard,
which is in turn based on
Bar-llan and Beaver from '89.
In this Cramer and Damgard
protocol which was
allegedly presented for computing
the inverse over finite fields,
there we keep at all places
the adjugate and
determinant separate.
P must be large enough so that we
don't go get a rep rounds,
and here that's easy to compute.
It's essentially the Hadamard
bounds for that matrix A.
Here, or I call the matrix M,
where I used to matrix A before.
Anyway, this B is a bound on
the elements of that matrix,
and then that's
the Hadamard inequality,
where it essentially
means here is
that I still have to
compute this product.
So then in order to
represent that product,
I need to slightly
increase P, of course.
Well, the protocol
goes as follows.
>> Does that mean that
the determinant should be huge?
>> Yes, the determinant.
There's a question here that
asks if the determinant
can get large or huge.
Yes, that is indeed the case.
So, we are doing
exact arithmetic here,
which means that you have
an inherent size growth.
On the other hand,
if you would like to
do approximative arithmetic or
say floating point arithmetic,
you would have to first built
a floating-point computation
in multiparty computation,
which is also expensive.
So there's a trade off
there and depending
on your application,
you might use this approach.
This works well for
small dimensions,
and if you have, say,
a prime of 200 bits
or thousand bits,
you can still handle many cases.
But on the other hand, if
you have a huge matrix,
there's no way that
you are, well,
this will not be
efficient because you
have this big growth and you need
a huge prime and making
computations with
that big prime is heavy.
So, indeed, there's
no free lunch.
So the protocol goes as follows;
I know this matrix A has
entries that are secret
shared over the field of
p and we are going to sample
a lower and upper triangular
matrix at random,
where this L is actually
unite triangular.
So it says has ones
on its diagonal.
Then we're going to compute
the product of this L and
U which we call R. Let d be
the determinant of
R. We can compute
that determinant immediately from
the diagonal elements of U.
Now, we are going to
compute the product of R and
A and reveal this product.
So, we make the product public
and it's this art and access
of blinding matrix for A.
Now in the clear,
we can compute the adjugate
and the determinant of A,
for example with the
Bareiss algorithm.
Then, well, we move to
blinding and and go back to
the secret shared world by
multiplying from the right
R and the inverse of
the determinant to
get the adjugate of A
and the determinant
of A is equal to
the determinant of
RA times the inverse of
d. If you would
compare this algorithm to
or this protocol to the one
from Cramer and Damgard,
making this L unit
triangular actually somewhat
simplifies the proof
because in their protocol
they do not use
a unit triangular matrix,
and of course they don't keep
this determinant and
adjugate separate.
Yeah, this gives you
way a constant rounds
or constants rounds
protocol with squared,
order and squared local work.
Here this n squared
assumes that I have
a cheap inner product as Shamir
has cheap inner products.
So that if I
do vectors of length n and I
compute the inner product,
that's as expensive as just
computing one multiplication.
Because I can compute
all these multiplications in
parallel which is local work,
and I don't count it and I
just have one re-sharing,
so one interaction with
the other players.
All right, now I want
to show this protocol,
how you can implement
this in MPyC.
So, I'm going to switch back to
my mirror screen to the browser.
It could be bigger here.
I'm not going line by
line through this
implementation but I
just want to see that
if you are working
on such protocols,
it's quite easy to
implement it in this MPyC
and check whether you
didn't forget something.
So, here is just an
implementation in
plain Python of the
Bareiss algorithm
and this computation is
one that happens on
public data because it run on
this non-secure part
or the opened matrix.
So, well, we believe that that
is a correct
implementation of Bareiss.
Here, I wrote a wrapper
to be able to use
some NumPy functions.
For example, for the part where
we have to sample
the random matrix,
we are first creating
this lower and upper
triangular matrix and NumPy
provides these handy functions
for arranging data at
a certain way in a matrix.
I can reuse that actually for
my secret matrices because NumPy,
well, has a parameter
where you can specify what
the element type of the matrices
or objects should be.
So, this is another
example of where
an MPC framework that
is implemented as
a library has a flexible way
of interacting with
the features of
the host language which
I make use of here.
So here, well, I create
a random vector.
I divide or compute
the inverse of
the product of
the diagonal elements of
the matrix U and here
it is mpc.prods.
That's a product tree,
so it's a logarithmic depth,
a product over a list.
So it's a fault over list
that is running parallel.
Here, I actually use
the multiplication operator from
NumPy and I apply that
to the secret matrices.
But actually, MPyC there is now
also a matrix product operator.
Anyway, this function gives me
the blinding matrix R and
this inverted determinant
of the matrix.
Then here, this is
the actual function
which is a co-routine and
MPyC makes use of asyncio which
is the asynchronous
API of Python.
I think you have
function definitions
that use the keyword
async, async def.
There's also
a decorator here which
is from MPyC that does
some bookkeeping.
Anyway, here's
the top-level script.
I have a matrix,
I secret share the elements and
then I run the protocol
and I open the result.
Here, well, we get the output.
Again, this is just
to demonstrate
that in a few lines of code,
you can quickly
implement the protocol
and see whether things work out.
Questions about this part?
>> Does MPyC look at
A and decide how big
the modulus needs to
be and [inaudible].
>> The question is,
how does MPyC know the modulus?
Well, there's
a default modulus that had
picks if you don't
specify one and in
this case we just get
the default choice
because it allows me to
compute up to 32 bits or
even bigger actually with,
only the comparisons
are limited to this.
But if I need a bigger modulus,
I can just specify that.
So, if you would have
an actual application,
you would look at
or find an upper bound
for the elements of
A and then apply
Hadamard algorithm and then or
the Hadamard bounds
and based on that,
it sets the correct
prime or set the bit
length of the prime.
>> Okay.
>> Okay, we have 15 minutes left.
So, then I want to
continue our comparisons.
So, in the '80s there
was Andrew Yu who proposed
the millionaires problem,
and today you would call it
the billionaires problem,
and they want to know who is the
richest without revealing
their account statements.
But let's assume that
these billionaires are
extremely paranoid and they don't
want to run a
two-party MPC protocol
because they are
afraid that somebody
has a quantum computer in
his backyard and text protocol.
So, let's go to a three
party protocol where MPC can
actually offer a quantum
resistant solution.
Yu, who's probably
not a billionaire,
maybe he'a a millionaire
I'm not sure,
but he just runs as
a third party as a helper party.
So, he is involved in
the protocol but he does
not provide any inputs,
and he does not get
to see any output.
But he's just there
as a helper party.
Warren Buffet and Bill Gates,
they essentially want
to do a comparison.
So, you have two inputs a and b.
You can subtract them,
and then determine the
sign of the difference.
That would be comparison.
Then of course you can
distinguish between,
say the proper signum function,
where you have also a
zero here as outputs.
This is a ternary output
or you have the greater
or equal than zero function
which has a binary output.
In this part of the talk,
I want to evaluate the sign
using Quadratic Reciduosity.
So, if you carefully
pick a prime,
then you could have
the situation where
the Legendre symbol coincides
with the sine of a number,
over certain range around zero.
Where this range -d up to
+d can be of size order L,
where L is the bit
length of the prime.
This idea goes back
to Feigh from 94 that
used this trick to
compute the sign of
a number in an interval
minus two to plus two in F7,
and more recently by you,
and this was explored for
much bigger primes and
see how you can build
a comparison protocol from that.
That's on eprint,
the paper by you.
For example, for the prime 311,
which is by the way Blum prime.
Because it's a Blum prime,
minus one is not a square.
So, we have nice
odd symmetry around
zero in the Legendre symbols.
Here up to 10 or up to 11,
and including 10, we have
this correspondence between
the Legendre symbol and
the sign of the numbers.
Because of this Blum property,
things look the same or
mirrored at the negative part.
Yes. So, this could
be viewed as a way
of determining the sign of
numbers in a small range.
We can use this idea also
in an MPC I should say,
if we can efficiently
evaluate securely
the Legendre symbol.
The complete multiplicativity of
Legendre symbol admits the
following for clover protocol
for computing it.
So first, in an offline phase,
we would compute
a random field elements
together with its sign.
Then in the online face,
the x here is the input,
we multiply it by
this random field elements.
So, we blind it, then we
can open this product,
and we then can compute the
Legendre symbol of that C as
a clear text computation
and compute it with
the secret shared sign of
that pair to get the results.
Can do this in
one communication round.
There's one caveat here,
namely that we cannot use
this to evaluate zero,
because then we would kill
here immediately the product,
and the adversary can see
that we input zero there.
But let's ignore
this for this talk.
We have written a paper,
and of course there
we do care about it,
but here let's just assume
as if we can compute
the Legendre symbol securely
and not worry about
the zero that we actually
have to circumvent.
>> In your case the time
did not have to be enormous
to have this property that
you need or would expect,
if you want the interval to be
non-trivial the prime would
be ridiculously large.
>> There's a question here
whether the prime has
to be ridiculously
large or to end up with
a usable or reasonable interval.
Yes. There is indeed this log B.
But I do have a table at the end
of the talk that shows
some practical values,
and indeed you won't
have an extremely
large comparison range
or sign evaluation range.
But still for
certain applications
it could be interesting.
But let's come back
to that later.
Anyway, this is basically
the idea of Feige
and this Yu paper.
Now, the question is how
can we increase the range?
Of course, we can just
pick a bigger prime,
and then we will get
a somewhat bigger range.
But the question that we
posed in this work
is whether we can
get a bigger range while we
keep the bit length
of the prime fixed.
Why would we be
interested in that?
Well, there's a cost associated
to increasing a prime.
Well, in this work what we do,
if we look again
at this 311 prime,
then if you look at
this error, so to speak,
then the sign function
is not such an interesting
function, right?
There's not much happening here.
It's just a constant line.
Only some interesting stuff
happens around zero,
where you have to transition.
But here you could actually
peek at your neighbors,
and do a majority vote,
and repair that error.
So, you take the sum
of the Legendre symbols of
your neighbors and yourself,
then you get in a range of
minus three plus three,
and then you would
have to compute
the sign of this y of x.
You can do that with
yet another invocation
of the Legendre protocol,
or you could use a polynomial
to find that sign.
Well, in this case we look at
one neighbor at each side.
So, let's say K equals one,
and we have a window length
of length three in this example.
So, 2k+1.
But we can generalize
that and have
the following definition where we
define the k range of P.
Well, where you take a bigger
'k' and hence a bigger window,
and you call 'd' the
largest integer such
that you still have
correctness for this method.
We set d_k(p) to zero,
if you cannot find such a 'd'.
With this definition, we can
now go to the table
of some examples.
Here the first column
gives you the 'd_0(p)',
which exceed
the Fieger Style Range,
and if you have window length
of three then you
get this 'd_1(p)',
and if you have a
window length of five,
so you look at two neighbors on
the left on the right you
have got this 'd_2(p)',
and if we look for example,
here at the 32-bits prime,
where we get the range of 96.
Here if we look at 32-bit prime,
we get threefold improvement
and here you have
already eight bits
range plus sign,
so, essentially nine bits.
So, there could be applications
where you are
interested in working
with this low or
medium range numbers.
If we go to k equals
two for a 32-bits,
we would actually be here is 458.
So, compared to the zero,
that's almost a five fold
increase in the range.
Well, I've-, question, sure.
>> [inaudible] Is
there any trade-offs?
I mean, can you compute
five [inaudible]
cheaper than one other
than five single once?
>> That's a question that
you'll also have to increase
the local work, yes.
That's true, that's a trade-off,
you still need to compute
those resemblance symbols.
I'm not aware of a method
to compute them all together
in a more clever way,
but indeed you do have to
do more local local work.
But one example where it
could pay off is that,
say you are on
the embedded platform
and you also have
memory restriction,
so you don't want your numbers to
be too big because you
have to store them,
then maybe you can exchange
space for time and yeah.
>> Did you also look
at different primes,
using C3 primes and then
taking the majority vote?
>> Another question here
is whether we looked
at taking different primes and
then take a majority vote between
the results within
those prime fields,
and the answer is no, we did not.
I think you can do that,
would be an interesting
direction to look into.
But also with, say
the setting in mind
where we usually work
over single prime fields.
>> They would have to be shared.
>> Yes you would have to do
things between
those prime fields.
So, there would probably be
modulus conversions be involved,
which are not for free.
So, we applied
these comparison methods
to the evaluation of
neural networks and this is
a multilayer perceptron from
a paper from 2016 from
Courbariaux et al,
which is for eminists.
So, here we have
this handwritten digit,
and we want to
recognize the digit,
and we want to do this or
evaluate this in
multiparty computation.
So, how the multilayer
perceptron works is,
well it's a bit small here,
but it's- there's a matrix of
parameters and the elements of
this matrix are minus
one or plus one,
so binary in some sense,
and you do a
matrix-vector product,
where the vector at
zero is actually
the image that has been
flattened to a vector.
Then there's also bias factor
that you add there,
and here the non-linearity
is taking the sign.
So, that maps well
with our work here,
and then you do
these matrix vector products
and taking science through
a couple of layers,
and at some point you end up
with a vector of length 10,
where each entry gives you
an estimate of
the probability that's
the digit is
that particular number.
So, the probability
for that it's a zero,
probability for one et cetera,
and then you could
take an arc marks.
Yeah, so we have implemented
this in M part C,
and report on the results
in an upcoming paper.
Okay, this concludes my talk.
Thank you very much
and I think, yes.
I stayed within
an hour, thank you.
Any further questions
for the room?
>> So, I have a question about
the linear algebra evaluation.
So, you sampled
some random matrices L and U,
and then you publish
the L times U
basically times
the secret shared measures.
So, can you prove
that doesn't leak any
information about
the secret matrix?
>> There's a question about
the linear algebra protocol,
whether the blinding operation
and then opening
the blinded matrix does not
leak sensitive information.
Well, the answer is
yes. There is a proof,
and the proof largely follows
the proof from [inaudible] ,
but it even simplifies
a bit because we've got
notice unit triangular
structure on L,
and then it's as easy as
showing that there is
a bijection so that
things are fine.
>> Okay, and also.
So, for the determinant
evaluation,
so you sometimes
need to divide by
the determinant which is,
because of these samples,
those random matrices kind
of uniformly randomly.
The determinants can be like
a random number in
the finite field right?
So, it's not necessarily
smaller than route p. So,
in that case can you still
do the rational reconstruction,
when the denominator
can be arbitrary?
>> There's a question
about the determinants
and dividing out
these determinants
and also in relation to
rational reconstruction.
First thing to mention is that,
we do not use rational
reconstruction because we
circumvent it by keeping
the educator and
determinant separate.
So, we never perform a division
that is known exact.
Maybe that already
answers your question?
>> Yes.
>> But otherwise let's
take take it offline.
>> [inaudible] . Okay?
>> Thank you very much.